so who has two middle fingers and should
be flicking himself off because he
recorded over you had another
adventuretime v-log with Jason this guy
yes I promise this isn't going to be a
regular I I've been trying to clear
things out of my computer to clear up
space because you know as always it's
acting great but yeah and that was one
of the things that deleted but you
deserve a be like damn it so this is
real fast this is the chamber of frozen
blades and I'll try my best to talk
about what Jason said I'm sorry I
I hate screwed up like this but Disney
Center all this stuff it piles up so ok
so this is an episode where Finn and
Jake they're waiting at the ice King's
plays their stakeout and they talked to
the fire as can happen on this show and
they see the Ice King leaves and they
think he's gonna do something evil so
they're gonna go and start wait for him
and they come across his secret stash of
ninja stuff apparently the Ice King
really wants to be a ninja
and they keep looking around thinking
there's like a princess he's kidnapped
or something like that and they can't
find her and the more and more they keep
looking the more and more they find is
this incredible ninja obsession and in a
strange way they kind of find they have
a little bit in common which I like I
like when a hero a hero can see that
like maybe evil is not that bad and the
Bell can see maybe the hero's not so bad
you know empathy that whole thing so
they go in and while trying to learn
about the ninjutsu way the way to
secrecy and not leaving a trace they're
constantly destroying everything and of
course leaving tons of traces so that's
going on but by far the best part is
when the Ice King is going to the
hospital and freezing people him
probably killing them and he is taking
Gunter to the hospital because you don't
really know what's going on that you
find out if he gives birth so good
there's not even a he
yeah yep I think the ice king king keeps
calling him a he which makes even
funnier
oh but still has his princess fetish so
he says that he wants a princess in the
room and they just so happened to have a
doctor called dr. princess and can't you
really like this character because she
is such a horrible doctor
she's just god-awful at this you know it
takes this depth of snow stethoscope it
like puts it in good dears pages yeah
night the good doctor came to see
stethoscope um and they see the talk
guter gives birth
yay and Ice King goes home and Finn and
Jake feel terrible because they feel
like they've destroyed this place and
you know there were such bad ninjas we
jump to conclusions he's fine then they
start to leave and it turns out he
kidnapped the doctor it is duffle pack
so and they have a little fight at the
end this little binge of fight doesn't
go on for very long
uh and then the egg hatches and go to it
turns out gave birth to a kitty and the
ice king says why didn't you tell me and
it ends there so I haven't seen the next
episodes I have no idea that's of course
it's not gonna be addressed when do they
the way this show works is that they're
gonna address something it has to be
like five eight twenty episodes down the
line before it's ever addressed which I
like you know again because it's you
know you have to keep watching cuz
you're not necessarily gonna get in the
next episode but maybe further down a
lie it's actually very clever I think
about Oh but yeah it was a lot of fun I
I love like I said how finn and jake he
gets so obsessed with something and
actually caused more damage than they
think they are but I like how it's it's
kind of justified cuz he's still doing
the wrong thing Jason Jason had this
theory that Gunter was still a boy and
there's one scene where the Ice King
looks at good dresser looks under him
almost checking his privates and just as
long anyway and I took that as he's
it was a girl and then threw her back
but Jason took it more as like he just
sort of looked at like huh no that's a
boy anyway and that it's just something
that's never explained so I don't know
if they ever clarify and I can't
I don't think Jason ever told me like if
they clarified whether or not it's a boy
or a girl but he was leaning more
towards it's a boy so that's what I'm
guessing that they don't come here fire
if they do clarify it's still a male
that maybe it's like Godzilla the
Matthew Broderick what produces a
sexually I don't know uh but no it's a
funny episode I love that randomness at
the end with the cat I'm I'm really
hoping that comes back in a strange
bizarre way goose becoming one of my
favorite characters and I don't I don't
know why he just does nothing but sits
there and something about our generation
really has this appreciation for
characters that just do nothing and sit
there and are just doing their own thing
probably for that very reason they're
just relaxing enjoying themselves and
don't give a what anybody thinks
give her the big lebowski mentality uh
hoping that comes back it's I know I
know like in terms of humor its funnier
if it's never address and never comes
back but oh god I want to know I want to
know that what did he did he or her get
with a cat is it I hear her was it I
hear her cat that he or her got with
it's just so many questions and that
that just makes it all the more funny
that they end with just them kicking the
crap out of the Ice King and it stops
there so it was very very funny yeah
like I said I think the best stuff was
in the hospital and that really made me
laugh that's about all I got on this one
so again I'm so sorry guys I'm gonna
keep better organized here because you
deserve V Logs with the gauze that y'all
so um yeah that's about it next one you
will definitely see V log with them
because I'm gonna go do those tomorrow
night so hopefully I will see you guys
there and
last time a jackass record over another
one you'll see the laws again take care